[Music]
I keep meeting new people yeah and you
know when you meet somebody who's like a
really complex character you just write
about them tailors the way of
songwriting style hasn't changed much
since then
are you ready for it
twenty-eight-year-old stuns on the
August cover of Harper's Bazaar inside
she poses and candidly interviews Pattie
Boyd the model who inspired songs from
the Beatles
George Harrison and rock icon Eric
Clapton like I don't understand how you
cannot fangirl about that boy discusses
what it's like to inspire songs while
Taylor opens up about writing songs
about moments and boyfriends quote there
are mystical magical moments
inexplicable moments when an idea that
is fully formed just pops into your head
and that's the purest part of my job is
it cooler to said oh is it you the Turin
MA but spending time with someone
doesn't always make them great source
material she adds there have been people
I've spent a lot of time with who I just
couldn't write about it's just that some
people come into your life and they have
this effect on you so your life
continues to be inspiration it's I think
you have to live a life in order to be
inspired by that life and so the more
people that I meet that make me feel
things it's like I just I write songs
about those people
you
[Music]